[Music]  doubt tells me i cannot break this wood  but doubt exists only in the mind you  know what i say to my mind  [Music]  now you okay  [Music]  [Music]  all right who let the kid in  i thought he was a tiny man  what's wrong with you  you seriously think a puny little child  can be a villain um  yes i am pretty despicable you don't  want to crush me  evil is for adults who steal powerful  ancient stones and wreak havoc  and not for tubby little punks who  should be at school  learning  taking a recess  suck i can't stop  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  hope you enjoy the rest of your short  life  you stole from us and now you're  [Music]  guys  oh  why don't we make this a fair fight  [Music]  oh you thought  [Music]  i get it but i need a good night's sleep  so get out oh fine because you had the  nightmare  yes  i just want to get some sleep  delicious  with every calories  okay  oh  [Music]  oh  [Music]  oh yes please  [Music]  oh  [Music]  hey  [Music]  uh  no no  [Music]